I'm going to be talking about online
changepoint detection using sports
training and so my name is McConnell a
so that about me I'm a senior data
scientist at psi Q where I work on the
research team and I create prototypes to
optimize marketing campaigns I'm also a
instructor University of Washington
School of Continuing Studies where I
currently teach a class on data
engineering okay so I thought I'd start
to discuss the importance of change
point detection by talking about a few
examples so I'm going to talk about
genomics marketing and Finance and so in
genomics we can examine the change
points in the AC gh profile which is the
comparative genomic hybridization
profile of DNA and we can use that to
identify involvement of genes and cancer
or other diseases so we use the change
going to detect that and then in
marketing so this is kind of a graph of
data a time series data and change
points in the data and in marketing we
can identify things like turn or you
know customer engagement changes so it's
very useful for areas like online retail
so we can adapt much faster to customer
behavior and in finance so this is a
Microsoft stock between 2015 and 2016 so
there was a huge change points around
September and so theoretically if you
could pick up on that change when you
can make a lot of money so I know that
stocks don't quite have a theoretical
distribution but you can see that there
was a big change in the stock price
okay so in the past changepoint
methodologies took a batch of historical
data and then they would look for the
change points in that historical data
and so this is useful for some cases but
when we look at streaming we want to be
able to detect whether the data there's
a change point as the data comes in so a
spark streaming is actually perfectly
suited for this use case so that's the
one I think I use in my project so in
trying to figure out what is the best
way to detect change points in real time
as data comes in in a stream I looked at
a lot of research and the two main
studies that I found were the most
suited for this use case were
nonparametric algorithm and a Bayesian
statistics algorithm and so in the
nonparametric method we have two windows
and each one contains n observations and
they're the one window one contains the
most recent n and the second window
contains one before that and so we find
a distance function that we define and
it's off to ask the user to define the
distance functions based on what suits
us and so that we're then that's where
the nonparametric part can come in and
so if this distance is greater than an
alpha then we we say that there was a
change point in the data and so in the
bathing area if we look at space there
and for those of you are not familiar
with Bayesian statistics with Bayesian
Bayes theorem is a theorem for computing
conditional probability and so in the
area of Bayesian statistics we basically
say that we have P of a the probability
of a that's our initial assumption about
the data about the
region of the data and so we start off
with our prior distribution the P of a
and then as data comes in that data is
our observed data or our likelihood and
so when you take the product of those
two simply the products so are our
posterior our actual distribution what
we assumed to be the distribution of the
data is proportionate to a product of
those two the prior assumption and the
likelihood for the actual data the
observed data okay so using a Bayesian
algorithm means exactly that that as new
data comes in or we start with a prior
assumption as and as new data comes in
we keep updating our assumptions are
updating our distribution so this suits
our our needs perfectly for detecting
online change points yes
and the point
five million
they're not like how do you know quite a
bit
quite salty sauce yeah there's a burning
usually in statistics and statistics we
like to have a good burning period but
the first point so I'll get to it here
so the first point always so we're
actually remodeling the number of
observations they'll change point so
when you have a change point you'll you
will have had zero observations till
exchange points River right now we're at
a change point so the first observation
is always going to be a zero right it's
right now we don't have any anything
prior so it's going to be a change point
and then as new data comes in we
currently create our you know Bayesian
distribution as data more and more data
comes in and then we can look for you
know another change point and then again
the number of data points will change
point is zero and so on so we have this
P gap right the distribution between
change points so every time we have a
change points we basically evaluate
based on that P gaps of distribution
till the change point it's a reusing the
the hazard function over here and as a
as I've mentioned in answering the
questions we have RT which is the number
of observation till a change point and
we start off with zero and as we
progressed incremented by one every time
we don't see a change point until we see
a change went and then is zero again so
modeling this and instead of looking at
the data is gives us better results
okay so there are limitations and that's
where our windows function comes back
and so we you know in theory it's nice
we can as data comes in we can keep
updating our distribution but in
streaming theoretically we could have
data that goes to infinity so if we're
doing something like matrix operations
it can become very you know cumbersome
and so we need to come up with a
solution so this doesn't get out of hand
and so a good example is global warming
so if we want to determine the if there
is an increase in temperature today we
don't look at measurements from the dawn
of time we'll look at you know the last
hundred years or even two hundred but we
don't care for you know thousands of
years ago it so it's a reasonable
assumption to make that you can pick a
large window of observations in
computing your posterior distribution
and then because we're using sparks so I
wanted to just introduce
accumulators the accumulators are a
variable in spark that can retain
information from prior micro batches so
the way it's flag works for extremum
works is that you you get micro batches
and you process them but there's no
memory between them so every time you'll
just process the batch as it comes in
but accumulators can store information
about previous batches and so in this
case so you can create by default in
numeric one I think the super fun is
just to take a sum or as data comes in
to accumulate right and then oh but here
I created an accumulator Q and the Q and
Q is of size max Q size and so I mean
it's pretty large but once you do that
limit you're just keeping the last max Q
size observations so here I have my
definition of the very cute
the accumulator Q so we define the
accumulator with a DQ right in Python
and then it's of max queue size and then
you define it as a global so that whole
program can see it
so a case study I looked at is whether
so I might company we look a lot at
weather and how it changes consumer
behavior and sales and so one way to
look at weather is to look at at the
number of standard deviations from the
mean if people perceive something to be
hot or cold is it two standard
deviations from looking forward or two
standard deviations from the mean is
very different from you know Nebraska is
two standard deviations from the mean or
or Alaska is two standard deviations
from the mean but we've noticed that
sometimes consumer behavior will change
more if there's a big shift a bit big
drop in temperature rather than if we
have something that bigger and variation
so I looked at the temperature for the
cloud nine eight zero zero six which is
Valdez and I looked at temperature from
September 2016 - February 2017 and
identifying the change point in this
data will help us identify abrupt
temperature shift growth temperature
shift so as I said our process is that
certain changes in weather influence
consumer behavior more than absolute
temperatures and we also think that
these changes influence behavior more
than relative temperature
I'm going to go into a demo
so I've created a pipe spark streaming
script that basically takes our kind of
fly yeah oh yeah sure goodness so on one
hand I have a copper cube and in this
case for the demo I write to the topic
the weather between September and
February and so that's our like peak
winter season and we wanted to look at
products that are related to cold
weather and whether they're influenced
by ships and temperature and then I also
have a
I also have a spotter and as I said a
spark streaming script and it has an
accumulator and
I keep writing through the accumulator
and creating a a and
n plus 1 by n plus 1 matrix and that
could I compute the letter console so
I'll show I'll show you that in a sec
okay so if i run the takes 10 seconds
and I'm going to be writing to the cute
I just I put in a one-second sleep in
between so that it comes in as a micro
batch of one line so every time spark
runs we get one temperature observation
and then I create a creator like I said
a matrix and I compute the probabilities
for the contour plot so over here as I
mentioned there's a burnin period so in
the beginning it just says so this is
this would be the output of that spark
job so in the beginning we have I just
says you know there's okay so there's a
burnin period and we say there's no
change points but after a while it
starts picking up on the change points
and so each like white line at a slope
basically says you know this is a time
period where weather is stable and then
it drops to zero right there's going to
change points in the weather and you
know goes up again and you know drops
again and such that the gear is just
playing and repeat so the the spark job
creates the but the numbers to create
this contour plot yes how do you do with
me
so the question is how do we deal with a
slow change well we're actually not
interested in detecting those because we
make an assumption that they don't
really influence behavior as much so
we're just interested in big spikes and
so we want those spikes to be kind of
more relative to the environment and we
don't want to just define our
temperature went down by 10 degrees then
trigger you know from cold wet lettuce
milk advertising campaign we don't want
that we want to know its temperature
just went down abruptly so we use this
algorithm to define what abruptly means
so additionally I plotted yes
this drop in temperature especially
looking at Bellevue and the season like
the temperature actually drops a lot on
the clear days so it could be in fact a
correlation with sunny versus not sunny
and so does this I guess when you're
looking for this like what is an abrupt
drop do you do any sort of like false
data checking first or are you just
trying to find like five degrees is a
good job or so I think what we're doing
is first we're identifying the drops and
then we're evaluating the scenarios
where that happened like you said if it
happened because of something else then
then we're going to roll those out so
we're basically with checking other
weather variables okay like you say okay
okay and then do you also set minimums
on the timeframe that this has to occur
in yeah only in winter I mean but like
over like a two day range to our range
okay now we just get a daily temperature
I think we might get every six hours
actually okay so we just look at what
was the change between those two
measurements as the data comes in okay
yes yeah I'm sorry
normally like every second like the next
point until a different of the first
point says we know I um you think if
there's an anomaly in the data a window
and say I mean sometimes like one
particular point me they may be changed
this point but virtually you consider
like a live the anomalous leader must be
like I can't reduce this is that that so
you define your hazard function and you
define what you're comparing to so that
kind of you can tweak the parameters of
as I say one anomaly might be you know
won't influence as much so it will take
like a critical mass may be - or is it
depends on the hazard function that you
define I suggest to keep the question to
the end of the talk okay
in order to thank you sure and then so
that was just one big curve but if you
look at the entire United States you get
this interesting period we I plotted
high posterior probability so the high
probability of a change point over a two
month period and you can see kind of a
growth the same as can the weather
pattern so I think this chart kind of
validate that the methodology and I've
charted it against weather and you can
see big spikes and also I charted this
again sales and it's interesting to see
that it saw some products that are
related to winter
we'll sell well a day after the cold
fronts kind of passes through the United
States I can't really show that because
you know customer data but so this
methodology is pretty good at picking up
on these trends okay
all right so any other questions I think
talk okay okay let's keep the question
to the individual ah ah okay good
what's your underlying distribution and
how do you pick the prior also here I
use just a constant hazard and I use the
t-distribution how do I pick I guess it
would depend on for the you make a prior
assumption so based on the behavior of
the data so it constant hazard so that I
export exponential distribution and then
you pick the prior because you use the
exponential distribution I think it was
we call it a X exponential family right
right I mean yeah
next question
quiet so you were using Kappa and I was
wondering and I was wondering if we can
see the producer code they used for
Kappa and also if you were using
multiple you were gathering this
information from multiple locations and
if at some point you were using an actor
for it no I mean this is just four and
this is like my code for the demo of a
prototype so just was it you know what
would happen like in my company I don't
really I wouldn't have the production
code for how many sources they would you
know if they use daca or those types of
things but they do use crafter as well I
can show you my code for the producer
just while we're bringing that up a
quick announcement lunches outside in
the hallways so when you've finished
enjoying your time here and there's
absolutely no rush to leave you can go
out and pick up a box lunch and take
that we're going to be showing some
interviews from the live stream in
cascade which is the next auditorium
across so if you'd like to sit down
there and watch a more in-depth time
with Andy Carroll who spoke this morning
and also some people from Microsoft to
help organize the conference feel free
to go and sit in there and have your
lunch in that watch the live stream
interview otherwise we'll be going back
to McKinley for one a roundabout one
o'clock for the next keynote from Jacob
and applause thanks okay yes sorry take
four just for this demo I'm not going to
really read data from NOAA in real-time
I just take a CSV file where I had my
data from NOAA and I pass it into the
stream for the topic one second it was
one second delay so each the idea here
is that each microbat should have one
observation because that simulates what
happens in real life you don't have to
temperature readings coming in at once
just the data from Bellevue and just the
minimum temperature for that day for
each day in the time period when I turn
off the logging right on did possible to
status lines with us huh is it possible
to status lines the presentations line
what do you mean I'll go back to this
why would you shoot I mean I should be
on like I send them to the organizers so
they should be shared probably after the
event
okay well because I went to John get up
I saw the the coat but I couldn't find a
slash oh yeah it should probably after
the event my beautiful little puppy
I'm like it helped I can put it on I get
help then okay
can you comment about the choice of this
model compared to a model that actually
model time series like a real model and
then like using the animal model to see
when you have a loud deviation and what
anything so an alternative to this model
because you want to find yeah okay so
the alternative to this model you can
actually view after this mode area and
look for a deviation in that model so
when an unpredictable value is coming
next that will that will point to a
change point right yes and can you
comment about differences in why one
method will be better than another now I
mean I don't know if one I don't know is
concentrated I you know familiar with
that method in I don't know if one is
better than the other necessarily I just
mean chose these this one
you know tested it and so I didn't I
didn't quite test how this would perform
within ARIMA model but and you know
definitely it is an option okay how did
you define the threshold value so that
you name some data point as an anomalous
okay how did you define special
generally that's Russell oh yeah so the
threshold will depend on I think that's
actually something we're researching
right now so we're developing like how
to detect the threshold but I feel for
when I looked at 0.5 as it is a safe
threshold any any probability of 0.5
any more questions follow up with the
with each question do you compare the
nonparametric method and this Visine
method and with one
I didn't the reason I started that paper
because I got the idea of using Windows
from that paper like a window not
Windows the operating system so so
that's why I use that paper but you
could use that paper I just we would
have to develop you know your on
distance function any more questions
okay thank you so much and by this we
close the session for today time for
lunch
[Applause]